vous êtes 7 millions d'abonnés sur ma
chaîne youtube pour fêter ça non je
réponds à vos questions vous m'avez posé
sur twitter com vous avez été quelques
milliards à ma demande et alors c'est
cadeau tu l'a embrassée comment ta
première copine alors j'étais super à
l'aise à tenter sur c'est comme ça qu'on
embrasse bien sûr d'accord tu aimes bien
être dans ton rôle de personnage
dégueulasse et mono sourcil avoue mois
n'a t-on smiley préféré que tu imitera
avec ta tête bien sûr pas tu faire un
one man show comme normal le goût alors
ce n'est pas prévu il faut savoir qu'un
one man show ça demande beaucoup
beaucoup de temps et je suis un branleur
je préfère consacrer mon temps à
réaliser ou à concevoir des petites
vidéos des courts métrages me sens plus
auteurs réalisateurs que stand-up heures
tu sais faire combien de pompes preuve
vidéo
est ce que tu t'es déjà pris un râteau
quand tu étais au lycée
oui tu veux sortir avec moi n'importe
quoi à cyprien si tu veux on peut
devenir amis non non ça je la mite non
ça je m'en fous ça je m'en fous je veux
vraiment sortir avec toi en fait tu va
refaire un court métrage parce que le
premier était géniale or déjà merci
beaucoup ça me fait plaisir parce que
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps dessus et
j'ai adoré bosser sur sur technophobes
et je suis effectivement en train de
décrire un nouveau court métrage peux
pas trop vous en dira beaucoup mais ça
sera une histoire d'amitié sur fond de
trucs un peu geek dans une période
médiévale
enfin ce spa prépares tu peux enlever
ton t-shirt en direct alors ok mais vous
moquez pas d'accord voilà pas très
glorieux quelle est ta meilleure
technique de drague
bonjour ces mois-ci prière non moi je
préfère le jdg slg d'accord et wtc y
penser rare en a compris quand tu fais
des vidéos dans le style snatch à
twitter apple ne ferais tu pas du
placement de produit alors j'adore cette
question parce que c'est vrai que sur
internet on aime beaucoup le complot
jean roch
gagnant de savoir que quand je fais une
vidéo sur top chef ce match à twitter
l'apple watch tout ça ce n'est pas du
placement de produit j'en parle parce
que ça me fait marrer tout simplement
donc il faut arrêter d'être paranoïaque
pour certains d'entre vous faut savoir
qu'une marque ne donnera jamais d'argent
pour qu'on détruit son produit je veux
dire que votre montre ne sert à rien
elle est chère la batterie tient pas et
votre pdg se mouche avec des billets
génial tenez 5000 euros logique internet
thé goûts musicaux former deux groupes
préférés c'est blur et radiohead grand
fan à ce moment au but pour des houmas
gueule à quand une prochaine
faq je fais quoi maintenant tu expliques
tu peux tu faire une imitation de
squeeze et norman et autoroutes et ce
président aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
un simulateur de simulateurs ces partis
au jeu malgré ce qui fait que quand on
pense qu'à jam au hockey jumbo s'en fout
d'accord fort c'est à croire que toutes
les filles sont mises d'accord trop mais
norman tu es trop moche ouais t'as trop
raison
super pourquoi tu ne fumes plus dans ton
appartement à vous avez remarqué un
effectivement je ne compte plus dans mon
appartement pour des raisons techniques
puisque avant je tournais face à une
fenêtre qui donnait sur une rue passante
avec des motos et des voitures qui
passent tout le temps et du coup j'étais
obligé de parler quand les voitures ne
passait pas c'était très très chiant
d'ailleurs je devenais même parano
j'avais l'impression qu'il y avait une
moto qui attendaient que je parle pour
accélérer quoi c'est je devenais fou
j'ai passé
on ajoute à ça la lumière qui changent
tout le temps à cause des nuages qui
parle en plus je pars très fort quand je
fais mes vidéos du coup tout l'immeuble
était énervé contre moi
donc en fait pour vous comme pour moi
c'est mieux que je tourne ici dans des
conditions un petit peu plus agréable
vous avez des vidéos d'une qualité
supérieure et puis comme je passe
énormément de temps ici en fait c'est un
peu comme ma deuxième maison
voilà je fais mes montages fait mes
trucs ça sent la pizza ça te fait quoi
de savoir que françois hollande toffolo
alors oui oui françois hollande me
follow tranquillement au calme sur
twitter ça veut dire que je peux lui
envoyer un message privé
wesh poteau ça fait quoi ce soir
j'espère avoir une réponse rapidement un
grand soir c'est un petit fifa entre
poteau quels sont tes futurs projets
alors je travaille sur beaucoup de
choses
un court métrage et de sketches sur ma
chaîne youtube
j'écris aussi d'autres vidéos plus
classique j'ai une série avec norman de
12 épisodes
une bd que j'écris en ce moment et je
dois parler plus tard bref j'ai pas mal
de boulot tu connaisses lg si oui tu
peux faire une parodie la vidéo qui va
suivre date du 30 2 mai et montre un
homme qui s'en va sur des objets mais
pourquoi il fait ça
j'aimerais bien aller un petit peu plus
loin si tu vois ce que je veux dire il
ne fera que ça en tout la vidéo je sais
que vos espoirs partent en fumée à
shopper au quiz ita dessinée
magnifiquement bien à ton tour de le
dessiner lui
[Musique]
voilà taille réelle il est grand comme
ça je connais bien il est vraiment grand
comme ça quelle est la chose la plus
bizarre qu'on paie dit une fois il ya un
jeune qui m'a reconnu dans un magasin il
m'a dit c'est toi cyprien j'ai répondu
oui
puis il m'a dit c'est vrai voilà donc je
sais pas si je vais me justifier
peut-être ici c'est moi regarde une
photo me ressemble tu avais un clown
comment tu le fasses audrey bail serait
exactement comme moi parce que c'est le
principe du clown est pas con et tu
allais au japon pour voir des hentai de
qualité qui font plaisir
n'importe quoi c'est pas du tout mon
genre
1 pourquoi des nouvelles lunettes rondes
a fait remarquer série que j'ai changé
j'ai pris mon temps les anciennes
étaient mieux
[Musique]
quelle a été la plus grosse bêtise quand
tu étais petit alors quand j'avais six
ans j'ai piqué une grosse crise parce
que
je voulais prendre un bain et mes
parents voulaient que prennent une
douche alors j'ai foncé tête baissée
dans la porte vitrée du balcon que j'ai
brisé totalement voilà du coup mes
parents m'ont donné une fessée du coup
j'avais mal aux deux extrémités
et puis j'ai pris une douche que ferais
tu si tu avais un death note alors un
death note ça vient d'un manga c'est un
carnet où quand tu écris le nom de
quelqu'un dedans
la personne meurt immédiatement alors
moi s'il y en avait un j'écrirai le nom
de personnes pourquoi cette vidéo font
moins rire qu'avant si tu aurais pas été
youtuber tu aurais fait quel métier tout
en tout cas tu aurais pas fait prof de
français
et voilà c'est la fin merci beaucoup
vous êtes des dingues
le hashtag cyprès répond est passé en
trending topics ce monde c'est n'importe
quoi vous êtes des fous et merci
beaucoup de suivre ma chaîne de me poser
toutes ces questions
de me suivre ça me fait extrêmement
plaisir 7 millions c'est un truc de
malade
si vous n'êtes pas abonné abonnez vous
peut-être qu'un jour on s'est revus
millions peut-être pas je ne sais pas à
bientôt
[Musique]
vous faites directement avec votre doigt
ils ont laissé sa réplique j'avais dit
qu'on ne mettait pas ça